hong kong democracy activist joshua wong
has been charged but released from
custody
on bail wong was arrested for allegedly
joining an
unauthorized demonstration last october
the 23 year old came to international
prominence as a teenage protest leader
he was barred from running in district
elections last year
he is the most high profile campaigner
detained since media tycoon jimmy lai
was arrested
last month and in a statement to dw
joshua wong's
fellow democracy activist nathan law
sharply criticized his arrest saying the
following
it is another outrageous attempt to
silence the voice of the freedom fighter
in hong kong
especially someone who has a leading
role like joshua the world must condemn
these arbitrary arrests and continue to
keep an eye on the deterioration
of freedom in hong kong
and we can speak to joshua wong right
now he joins us
from hong kong hi joshua you have been
charged you've been released on bail you
are expected to show up in court
next week so what is your next step
even i could left police station today
but this doesn't mean that
the risk is not exist anymore as you
have mentioned that i need to
attend the court hearing on next
wednesday which is 30th of september
one day before the chinese national day
and that's the chilling effect generated
by the authorities
hope to silence the voice of dissidents
before chinese national day
because president xi jinping faces but i
would say that
compared to what i need to face with the
maximum jail sentence
of five years related to participating
on authorized assembly
i wish the global community could put
more and more attention
to 12 hong kong protesters right now
detained in mainland china
with the secret detention and with the
secret child
because what i am experiencing right now
is at least
at hong kong police station and hong
kong courts and hong kong prison
but 12th protester what is experiencing
right now
is a nightmare and they need more
attention around the world
cheshire you're referring to for some of
our viewers who might not be aware
you're referring to 12 activists who
tried to flee to taiwan
they were arrested by chinese
authorities and now are being held on
mainland china
i want to come back to your case because
i i want to know
how you're going to fight these charges
what is your plan
uh it's the third time for me to be
prosecuted again since
last summer protest and uh among those
10 000 hong kong is being arrested
and amongst those 1600 hong kong has
been prosecuted
i would say that even the authorities
would love to exhaust us
through those complex boring and
uh long-term judicial procedure but the
threats could not defeat
us make us even stronger determination
no matter protests on street
our global efficacy or etc we still like
to hope to let the world
know that we still keep on our
resistance and no matter
july 1st of this year which is the
anniversary
of the transfer of sovereignty of hong
kong or on
a 4th of september which is the original
election day they've been canceled by
the authorities
or even until first of october i still
believe people will have the way
to have protests towards beijing hotline
crackdown
you said that you want to continue this
protest and that you are determined but
they've been going
on for a year and a half now we have to
say that the reaction from china has
been
this extradition law that that started
all this china has only clamped down
further it has imposed a national
security law we have mentioned that
elections
have been postponed and you yourself
have been barred from standing for
district elections
do you think it is time that you changed
your strategy
we continue our strategy no matter put
pressure inside the institution
apply to run for office protests on
street we try all of
our ways to maximize our public support
in local
and global community and also hope to
let authorities to know that
we will not choose to surrender in
different battlefields
and one point that i would like to
emphasize is even
beijing choose to censor me out from a
balance but beijing could not disqualify
my qualification continue to engage in
the democracy movement in hong kong
and at least we still have to let the
world to know that
hong kongers are still ready to stay and
fight
i want to ask you know many of your
fellow activists have been arrested some
have left since the security law was
passed we
just mentioned nathan law earlier a
fellow activist who's now in the uk
are you thinking of leaving hong kong
i will continue to stay and fight and i
hope to let people to know that
seeking global and local community
support
on the course to fight for free election
are both important
that's why we might have friends
continue their international efficacy
in countries around the world hong kong
is based in different countries
they are really critical and we also
have hong kongers
based in hong kong this hometown to
continue our resistance
and continue to facilitate
more and more protests and our campaign
and let the world know that we still can
keep our momentum
of course we face more and more
difficulties and the situation
in the september of 2020 of course
what is totally different with what we
experienced
in the september of 2019 but i think now
hong kong is just like the new east
berlin in the new cold war
and no matter within the hong kong's
territories
we experience the national security law
and even for the free world
also experience the roof warrior
diplomacy of china
and we still hope to send a clear signal
to china
it's time to hope their accountability
is not the way out
to crack down on hong kong and to erode
on universal value that we believe
pro-democracy activist joshua wong
joining us from hong kong thank you
thank you